[Music]
this morning the new thing in old music
classical conductor yanique nazae sagin
was born in canada but now acts as
musical director on both sides of the
border montreal philadelphia and at the
met here in new york
his career has been like a rocket ship
the energy he brings to each performance
remarkable jose again has designs on
making more than great music though he
wants to open the often stuffy world of
classical to a whole new audience
so far
it looks pretty good
[Music]
it's borderline drunk
music right and especially in the last
movement it's almost more fun watching
you rehearse
than actually in concert yeah
this is the kitchen you know the the
concert is the dining room
he is classical music's hottest
commodity
[Music]
yanik nazeh sagin grew up in montreal
displaying uncommon talents for arts and
showmanship at a young age
after pope john paul ii visited his
hometown in 1984
nazis again began delivering mass every
day in his basement how do you go from
wanting to be pope
to wanting to be a conductor isn't it
the same
[Laughter]
papal dreams may not have lasted but an
obsession with music did he became
director of montreal's orchestra at the
tender age of 25.
nine years ago he began leading the
orchestra in philadelphia
two years ago he also took over as music
director at the met in new york city yes
i don't have only one partner yes i have
three but it's
i i feel that i'm rotating between the
three families and
i can bring something different to each
of them
recently a full-length documentary was
released on his life yanik an artist's
journey
further elevating his already soaring
reputation does becoming a celebrity in
this world
make it more difficult for you to do
your job and to focus on the work
i mean celebrity it's uh it's it's it's
relative i guess there's a movie made on
you
it's true that i
it doesn't make my my
my life more difficult though not at all
we met nazis again in philadelphia where
things are changing fast
for one the traditional white tie and
tails are gone
in favor of a more modern style the
dress code here has changed
significantly if that's important to you
for me what's important is that we get
to the 21st century even if we play some
music from the 18th and 19th and 20th
it has to resonate with the people who
come today
how do you think classical music can
bring in a younger generation
they need to be exposed to it when
they're young music is a language
then as a conductor you communicate with
your gestures with your eyes i feel like
music was a bigger part of
my school growing up
than it is in a lot of kids schools
today how much of a problem do you think
that is it's a huge problem there's so
many studies that over and over again
prove that it's so good for kids to
have music as their background being
able to express
even if they don't become professional
watching nazis again conduct can be
mesmerizing an explosive combination of
facial expressions and body movements
that constantly push his performers i
like that you use your hands
as expressively
during the interview
as you do
up on stage
it's it's the way you communicate yeah
it's i can't help it that's true if um
i think i've always been this way but
yet i i've always been a conductor in a
way so yeah that's true yeah now i
realize but you're not thinking about it
i mean i love this question because
that's something that's very important
for me to for people to realize that
to be a good conductor the most
important thing is not to think about
the gesture the second you start
thinking about it it's over it's it's
something not natural
at just 46 years old
jose seguin has already built a life of
loyalty
he's been with his partner a violist in
the montreal orchestra for a quarter
century many feared he would leave
montreal for good as his star brightened
he agreed to become music director there
for life i think there was this worry
and every year they would say oh one day
yanik is going to leave one day and he's
going to leave and i kind of got tired
of this and said well guys i won't leave
and they say why don't we just stop this
thing about oh when are you going to
leave when are we going to renew and say
let's just get married and so that's
what happened which is very unusual for
an orchestra and conductor relationship
how do you think you've changed in the
last 20 years
i hope i didn't change too much
i still feel like a kid
what is it you haven't accomplished that
you still want to i want this music to
to touch even more people and to make a
difference in how also
it can bridge different cultures people
who think they have nothing in common
you put them on stage together or you
put them in the same concert hall and
all of a sudden because there are no
words they feel connected in a way that
nothing else
can achieve and i feel that is really my
goal i want that in 40 years when we
talk again i can say well this and that
happened and look now we're not talking
anymore like oh classical music that
elite thing you know no this is music
that lives and breeds everywhere let me
just put that in my calendar so that
would be
2061. yeah
why not
we'll book it okay we'll book it it's a
it's a it's a rendezvous
[Laughter]
it's a rendezvous how old will you be
then the first interview i booked in
2086.
uh the first interview i booked in 2061
so that'll be a nice return you can you
can come and i'll watch it at the time
but he is just a dynamo yeah and giving
everything he can to three different
orchestras
all at the same time i'll be watching i
hope